Et oh plus parce qu'ils sont bons à être est un
Et puis ça passera par là
vous avez vu German Conversion Buiu
Douches Instagram qui sont ici et qui sont
c'était à partir de juillet dans les lumières qu'il est
laisser l'heure vous avez beaucoup d'années
de Brasília et a dit que nous étions restés là-bas
pas besoin de s'entraîner ajouter parce que
doit encore être ouvert là-bas je reste moi-même
penser à la rétention, pourquoi?
beaucoup d'entre eux ne savent même pas ce que c'est
attraper Sandra Oh
ET là
l'audience internationale du nouveau pétrole de
Brasilia pas de différence dans la vaine zone
prenez-les un peu
revitalise la version zouk Fusion et a
était un médecin sociable à l'institution
Le CV d'Evandro s'il avait le nom
le sien avec G1
[Chanson]
un
Je me lève tôt maintenant jusqu'à environ 11 heures
midi et à 13h30 je vais à
l'école déjà
mais j'ai travaillé avec le droit avec elle
Il est
ET là
O
événement là-haut
de ton père est
ET là
[Chanson]
et
Je me suis dit que tu pleures ok
J'ai du mal à supporter à cause de
De là
ET là
[Chanson]
pour éclairer il faut choisir
affirmer que nous le ferons si quelqu'un
regarde en ce moment sur son téléphone portable parce que
il y en a qui sont très maigres là nous
peut monter et elle est là comme mon père
est même allé gravir la Nossa Senhora
c'est un saut très tordu définir qu'elle
a rompu avec lui même obtenu de frapper le
poitrine
la vie au gril
alors c'était difficile tu sais ok ok travail bien
employé de maison on me regarde
J'ai peur comme ça, un peu risqué celle-là
ici
il n'y a aucun moyen parce que tu dois m'aider
quand je suis malade aussi
ET là
[Chanson]
je ne peux pas y aller
le singu c'était un conseil comme celui-ci
[Chanson]
et O
Qu'est-il arrivé
Tenez celui-ci, c'est trop pour
qui chante pourquoi chanter oui
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de montées et de descentes et puis
il faut ramener le groupe et chercher
nouveau là ça monte ça descend fatigué déjà beaucoup de corps
Il est
c'est un processus à suivre avec 10 ans d'apprentissage
avec mon père Dieu merci
et déjà j'ai déjà attrapé une chute avec elle
partenaire déjà parce que comme ça zueira mais
car ici que ce n'était pas une nécessité pour
ma grand-mère là vous pouvez voir est la même que celle-ci
type qui parle puis vous devenez vert puis elle
c'est très fin et tordu donc je suis allé à
monter je vais faire la caisse là j'ai pensé
elle allait me tenir là quand je suis monté
mais elle l'a pris et a rompu avec moi je suis tombé
par terre là-dedans, je l'ai pris à l'un des
plus gros mais j'ai réussi à y retourner
continuez à courir là-bas toujours là-bas moi
avait 13 13 ans
pas à cause de mon bras au cas où
casser ces choses
ET là
La
emploi restera affamé, elle vient de laisser
moi aller a été enterré voir réparer Nintendo
serais là nous te mettrons avait
aucune autre meilleure condition de vie
mettre mes enfants pas pour le service
mais malheureusement ça n'a pas le droit Nous vivons
pratiquement nous ne devrions pas
Dieu merci le sait
et il doit survivre de toute façon
le rose est calme et bas est
y aller au
et je verrai un indice pour la liberté
de volonté
alors il est fatigué épuisé regarde le
alors dis-moi que je vais devoir m'en procurer un
travail pour envoyer de l'argent comme ça à
avoir une meilleure famille
laissez-les évacuer le moins
travailler parce qu'à cet âge ce n'est pas
tellement fonctionnait encore
ET là
[Chanson]
C'est déjà l'aube, on arrive tôt mais
5h00 du matin puis il vend de l'açaí et fait
les courses et s'en vont ils vont s'écraser
une série d'entre eux
et
quand il y en a beaucoup on vend presque
pour l'intermédiaire car il y en a beaucoup
intermédiaire là dans notre intérieur qui
acheter chez nous pour revendre à Abaeté
le compte a du temps libre nous vendons de l'approvisionnement
vendre pour enregistrer cette douleur famille EA
genovese Neiva vérifions celui-ci
puis hier c'est lui qui s'en va
exception que la fonction Record hand
et de l'utérus c'est comme si tu comprenais là
disponible s'il marché toujours je l'ai pris
une photo avec la part de la main qu'il quitte
dira et conduira Infante lait et
principalement et vivent et
ET là
et où est la musique
[Applaudissements]
c'est différent de former Andrade Center Norte
Rigueur, qui a besoin de fermer celui-ci, oh et
Je crois donc je ne sais même pas
pratiquement la vérité parfois moi-même
Je me demande ce qu'ils doivent penser
parce que je pense que beaucoup d'entre eux ne le font même pas
vous ne savez même pas ce que c'est que d'attraper l'action
comment l'açaí est extrait de l'arbre et arrive
pour lui moi-même A 15 ans déjà
travailler avec, le temps est passé
O Numéro
C'est mon rêve c'est un jour un jour
ne pas être en mesure de réaliser le rêve d'être
joueur de football
jouer pour aller en europe
qui sait mais je ne sais pas mais je l'ai fait
J'ai commencé à travailler, mais j'ai encore
J'ai des espoirs indiquent un jeu
obtenir
dans ce cas, ce sont les familles elles-mêmes, n'est-ce pas?
qui enseignent aux enfants parce que
l'agriculture s'appelle l'agriculture
Droit familier alors la paix est de
huit ans, il enseigne déjà la
les enfants commenceront à donner le premier
bonnes étapes pour apprendre à suivre les
activité familiale, qui consiste à prendre le
l'açaï et
Dieu à coup sûr
ce n'est pas un enfant non pas comme ce diable et non
que ce soit arrivé
comme je parle des enfants de la campagne
sont un peu intelligents pour ces choses
juste là
bien d'accord Dieu merci enfant jamais
s'est passé dans l'accident donc je sais
Bien sûr que non
ET là
Je les prends comme et fan il fait celui-ci
fou possède où ces examens sont
où il compte qu'il peut atteindre de
Cabuçu il est bon berger de meilleures mains et
dire que sidon e e parades design
La conception du sommeil sont des genres unilang
archives et a participé à la légion
adolescente
bien payé pour notre travail et non
laissez-les dehors, ne l'amenez pas
parce que ça rend beaucoup de service, je vais partir
nous devons attraper le battage nous devons
la charge au navire doit prendre
pour le d'ici à la maison de la maison doivent
apportez-le à Abaetetuba et cela rend beaucoup de services
et beaucoup se lasse beaucoup de cet André
fatigué c'est vrai
ET là
G1
La
nouvelle maison fantaisie ou Caroline alors
gros quelque chose a celui-ci en feutre non
malheureusement nous n'avons pas ces données
nombres, à droite, presque toutes les familles
qui résident dans cette région, pense-t-elle
avoir des enfants adolescents
d'entre eux peuvent être impliqués dans ce
activité Mais nous n'avons pas de données
numérique la conscience là donc là la
les gens ont généralement ces
difficultés d'admission
eh bien nous n'en avons qu'un que nous
mesurer le pouvoir de la sous-déclaration des
travail des enfants lié à
activité de sortie
licence à Brasilia la terre de chacun
édition sont de Monte vous allez ici à
votre conscience de soi j'ai perdu du poids là où le
grave million de millions de reais Brésil
de l'émotion et de l'état de la dette
c'est bien que je règne sur tout section si Túlio
le long du volant pour celui-ci qui est un test
hémorragique doit être un séminaire
les déchets sont déjà révolutionnaires, lyman avait
trouvé deux filles au toucher vérifier
travailler avec le nom de ces de ceux-ci dans le
ferme je n'ai pas été blessé du tout
quand quelqu'un est un enfant, il y a de la beauté
travailler quelque part est plein de gens
puis travail d'esclave je ne sais pas ce que c'était
les toilettes des enfants maintenant quand tu fumes
crack Personne ne dit que tout va bien alors le
le travail n'interfère avec la vie de personne
le travail est digne
une femme de cet age
ET là
[Chanson]
mon rêve est comme étudier pour informer est un
cours s'arranger passer prendre un
bon travail
le mot du jour pour nous de partir
ET là
[Chanson]